colchones tirados en el piso y
promiscuidad ningún distanciamiento
social parece posible en este día en el
único centro de acogida de lampedusa la
causa tras repetidos desembarcos en la
isla más de 1200 migrantes están
concentrados en este lugar esto es siete
veces más que la capacidad máxima de
este centro
una situación que deplora marta
bernardini activista humanitaria durante
más de siete años ha seguido las
repetidas llegadas de inmigrantes a
lampedusa este centro no está diseñado
para un número tan grande de personas se
supone que es un lugar transitorio para
acomodar a las personas durante sólo
unas pocas horas mientras que ahora se
quedan durante días y días la situación
se ha vuelto insoportable al límite de
la dignidad humana una situación que no
es inusual en este centro pero desde la
explosión del corona viruta en italia ha
despertado la desconfianza y el miedo de
los habitantes de esta isla que no tiene
hospital el covite empeora la situación
porque esta gente puede salir a comprar
cigarrillos comestibles o pizza y hay un
peligro cada vez mayor de infección ese
es el problema
la inmigración es un problema porque
cuando llegan 400 personas una tras otra
no sabemos si entre ellas hay una
persona enferma que contagia a todas las
demás
una aprensión que combate el cura de
lampedusa el padre carmelo hoy denuncia
una instrumentalización de la crisis
sanitaria en esta isla conocida por su
vocación de hospitalidad
los inmigrantes no representan un
problema de orden público ni de salud
porque a diferencia de los turistas los
inmigrantes están sujetos a varios
controles sanitarios controlada
destructiva no es tan bona ante la
emergencia el padre carmelo no dudó puso
a disposición su parroquia para alojar a
los migrantes ya que cree que la
situación de estas personas ha empeorado
con la pandemia algunos grupos de
inmigrantes fueron puestos en cuarentena
en el muelle del puerto a la intemperie
bajo el sol durante el día y por la
noche también así que le dijimos a las
autoridades que usaran nuestra casa de
la fraternidad como la llamamos es
nuestro oratorio no es lo ideal pero les
permite tener un techo
para el alcalde de lampedusa los
crecientes desembarcos de emigrantes en
tiempos de coronavirus son un desafío
difícil de gestionar denuncia el
abandono del estado central e incluso ha
amenazado con declarar un paro general
en la isla
tuve que ir a roma para hablar de la
emergencia en lampedusa el gran problema
es que no hay una estrategia por parte
del gobierno en pocos días pasamos de
200 a 1.200 inmigrantes aquí así que
justamente desde el punto de vista
sanitario los niveles de seguridad han
disminuido
esto es un verdadero problema
vemos que se va así este centro
inmediatamente porque no tenemos los
medios para cuidar de todas estas
personas
sin opciones el gobierno italiano
recibió la evacuación de los migrantes a
bordo de un gigantesco barco debido a
los fuertes vientos le es imposible
acercarse directamente a la isla
entonces es a bordo de este patrullero
de la guardia financiera que unos 800
migrantes son trasladados en grupos esta
mañana todos se embarcan en este ferry
en el que tendrán que pasar un periodo
de 14 días de cuarentena
luego serán llevados a centros de
acogida mientras que sus solicitudes de
asilo son examinadas
según la cruz roja ninguno de los
migrantes trasladados dio positivo al
coronavirus a todos se realizará una
prueba a bordo del barco y un tercer
examen en dos semanas sólo para
determinar tener como blanco a este
grupo de población específica para este
tipo de cuarentena personas que se
enfrentaron a un traumático viaje por
mar durante el cual arriesgaron sus
vidas es estigmatizarlos esta medida nos
deja perplejos
desde inicios de este año más de 20.000
migrantes han llegado a italia tras
cruzar el mediterráneo esto es cuatro
veces más que el año pasado en el mismo
período